we have a new AGI lab two battling
figureheads fighting over the future of
AI new exclusive accounts of what
happened in the last 48 hours and I
haven't even had breakfast this video
will not only cover developments up to
the last few minutes but we'll try to
provide one of the clearest accounts as
to what has transpired and the
personalities behind it this has truly
been a weekend that has changed the
course of AI let's start though with
this a series of posts on Twitter from
open AI senior staff saying open AI is
nothing without its people it seems like
the original openai is imploding in real
time and for some it's gotten personal
one research scientist at open aai said
Ilia does not care about safety or
Humanity this is just ego and power
hungriness that backfired and in the
last few moments we learned that Ilia
Sask himself regrets what happened he
says I love everything we've built
together and I will do everything I can
to reunite the company and at 5:30 a.m.
his time after presumably not having
slept at all Sam Alman hearted that
comment who knows what will come of that
but with perhaps 10 crazy Revelations to
get to I'm not going to spend too much
time on the Twitter Wars because first
and foremost we have a new AGI lab
within Microsoft Sam Alman is going to
be the CEO of this new group and Greg
Brockman is joining him of course with
what we've seen on Twitter it looks like
hundreds of open aai former employees
might be joining them the group doesn't
even have a name yet but with
Microsoft's compute they look set to
become one of the major AGI players and
the CEO of Microsoft has already
confirmed that Microsoft will quickly
provide this new group with the
resources needed for their success of
course open AI aren't yet dead and I'll
get to their new CEO in a moment but
first we have a bit more info about what
led to this Monumental split a key
division arose between the visions of
Ilia satova the chief scientist of open
aai and samman the CEO in October samman
moved to reduce suk's role at the
company which obviously infuriated him
then according to Bloomberg there were
announcements at devday that further
angered satova apparently the safety
team really didn't like the customized
versions of chat chbt that allowed
anyone to create chatbots and
particularly they didn't like the idea
of those chatbots becoming autonomous
agents but the rift goes further back
even than that this exclusive extract
from a book was released in the Atlantic
in the last few minutes apparently the
November release last year of chat BT
caused a rift inside the company one
faction felt the company and indeed the
world wasn't ready the extract says this
strained the already tense relationship
between open AI factions which Alman
referred to in 2019 as the different
tribes within the company the success of
chat chpt caught the company by surprise
and computing power from research teams
was redirected to handle the flow of
traffic these servers kept crashing and
safety teams within the company pushed
to slow things down when gbt 4 was
launched apparently customers tried to
take advantage of the $20 free credit
offered and then what happened was that
employees from the already small trust
and safety staff were reassigned from
other abuse areas to focus on that fraud
issue some employees in the safety team
struggled with mental health issues and
communication was poor in an ironic
twist co-workers would find out that
colleagues had been fired only after
noticing disappear on slack but
according to this book what also started
to happen was that Ilia satova began to
behave a bit like a spiritual leader his
constant enthusiastic refrain was to
feel the AGI and at one of their holiday
parties Sova LED employees in a chant
feel the AGI feel the AGI and in the
last few minutes we learned that ilas
satova was using that question do you
feel the AGI in job interviews this
researcher Adam Roberts ended up at
Google Deep Mind and it only gets
weirder from here apparently satova
commissioned a wooden Effigy that's like
a miniature statue and that was intended
to represent an unaligned AI he then set
that effigy on fire to symbolize open
ai's commitment to its founding
principles then things seem to have come
to a head when samman began to fundraise
for a billion dooll new chip Venture
that was apparently codenamed Tigris
which is a major river flowing through
the Middle East he wanted an a High
Focus chip to compete against Nvidia
there are strong hints that Sam Alman
not being candid about this activity
could have been the proximate cause of
the firing anyway I've covered the
15-minute firing in my previous video
but now for an hour by hour account of
what happened after that well the first
thing that happened was that the CEO of
Microsoft which don't forget has
invested 13 billion into open aai was
apparently livid at the announcement
remember he was blindsided and only
given a minute minut notice of the
firing for nadela don't forget open Ai
and gp4 was his way and I quote of
making Google dance and that investment
seemed to be crumbling before the shock
move that he made next but back to the
moments after the firing the pressure
from Microsoft and other investors
caused the board to even consider
resigning themselves apparently Sam
opman and Greg Brockman wouldn't return
with the current board in place at this
point it looked like there would be a
complete reversal with the board W and
satsa going and samman returning even
the interim CEO Mira murati apparently
was asking samman and Greg Brockman to
come back that's around the time we got
the tweet from samman I love the open AI
team so much that got 29 million
impressions and caused hundreds of open
AI staff to retweet Hearts everything
looks set for his return samman even
physically went back to the open aai
offices but remember his accounts had
been locked he had no access to to his
pass or his emails so this was him with
a guest pass and his not so subtle
message to investors and the board was
you don't have long to persuade me to
come back this is the first and last
time I'll ever wear one of these but he
may have pushed too far because what he
wanted was not only the removal of
existing board members including ilas
Sova but also a statement absolving him
of wrongdoing remember this was after
the board had initially agreed in
principle to step down and it seems that
statement was the sticking point that
caused the implosion of open Ai satsa
and the board refused to make that
statement and while this was going on
employees from openai were already
starting to apply for other jobs
apparently a handful had already applied
to Google deepmind and according to the
information dozens of other openai
staffers were announcing that they were
quitting the company coh here Nvidia
anthropic and Google Deep Mind were
actively trying to recruit staff from
open AI while some have speculated that
it was the bo that AR samon would come
back it seems far more likely that it
was Mira murati and other open AI staff
after all sver at this point was still
declaring that removing Alman was the
only path to defend the company's
Mission this was backed up by Ashley
Vance a writer at Bloomberg she said
Mira planned to hire Sam and Greg back
she turned team Sam over the past couple
of days it became a game of chicken
where the idea was to force the board to
fire everyone they figured the board
wouldn't do that and would back down the
board including satova went into total
silence but then they found their own
CEO his name is EMT Shar former CEO of
twitch and I'll get to him in a second
this was not however what samman was
expecting and according to a reliable
reporter Emily Chang Sam mman was in
shock at that appointment it seems he
really thought the board would back down
and put out that statement that he'd
done nothing wrong so who is the new CEO
of open aai and what does he think well
he clearly doesn't want open aai to die
with without a fight he said I took this
job because I believe that open aai is
one of the most important companies
currently in existence remember openai
still owns the chaty PT brand that alone
keeps them in an extremely strong
position especially with the general
public that don't follow all of these
Insider changes the new CEO also made a
few critical points he said our
partnership with Microsoft hint hint
remains strong that's almost to
reiterate to anyone wondering we still
have the compute we still have that
partnership sh is now surely engaged in
An Almighty struggle to keep as many
staff as he can obviously if they all go
even the chat GPT brand probably isn't
enough but this statement released in
the last couple of hours is interesting
for other reasons he admitted that the
process and Communications around
samman's removal have been handled very
badly which has seriously damaged our
trust he is apparently going to hire an
independent investigator to dig into the
entire process that's the classic new
CEO move I'm here to listen take notes
and investigate he also ended the
statement with this crucial point before
I took the job I checked on the
reasoning behind the change the board
did not remove Sam over any specific
disagreement on safety their reasoning
was completely different from that he
seems to be pointing back there to the
lack of honesty argument that was
originally put forward he then ended
with I'm not crazy enough to take this
job without board support for
commercializing are awesome models
nevertheless you can see why satova and
the board might have wanted to hire him
he said in September I'm actually in
favor of a pause or rather I'm in favor
of a Slowdown we can't learn how to
build a safe AI without experimenting
and we can't experiment without progress
we probably shouldn't be barreling ahead
at Max Speed either and in case it
wasn't clear where his views come from
here's him speaking for just a couple of
minutes outlining his views on the risk
I have a very specific concern AI we've
built an intelligence it's kind of
amazing actually it may not be the
smartest intelligence but it is
unintelligence it can solve problems and
make arbitrary plans at some point as it
gets better the kinds of problems that
we'll be able to solve will include
programming chip design Material Science
power production all the things you
would need to design an artificial
intelligence at that point you will be
able to point the thing we've built back
at itself and this will happen in before
you get that point with humans in the
loop it already is happening with humans
in the loop but that Loop will get
Tighter and Tighter and Tighter and
faster and faster and faster until it
can fully self-improve itself at which
point it will get very fast very quickly
and that kind of intelligence is just an
intrinsically very dangerous thing
because intelligence is power human
beings are the dominant form of life on
this planet pretty much entirely because
we're smarter than the other creatures
like my P Doom my probability of Doom is
like my bid ask spread on that's pretty
high because I have a lot of uncertainty
but I would say it's like between
five and 50 should cause you to
your pants but it's human level
Extinction I yeah no it's not just human
level Extinction it's extincting humans
is bad enough it's like potential
destruction of all value in the light
cone here I am being the guy who's like
the Techno Optimist and I am like no no
no the AI thing though this thing though
actually maybe may be a problem I have
no Financial stake in in either doomsday
planning around AI or the other weird
like double think 40 chess thing people
impute to oh we're actually trying to
build up open Ai and anthropic as being
and Google as being like super powerful
and it's all an ego thing about making
talking about how amazingly great this
stuff is so that we can like ear raise
more money for opening and Regulatory
capture whatever yeah and like like I
don't own any equity in any of these
things one of the key tasks of the new
CEO is surely to retain Talent like
Andre karpathy he was asked last night
why he wasn't commenting on current
events and said this I just don't have
anything too remarkable to add right now
I like I can respect Sam and I think so
does the majority of open AI notice he
said majority not everyone the board had
a chance to explain their drastic
actions and they did not take it and
then after the more recent announcements
he tweeted a symbol for radioactivity
something tells me he might not be
sticking around at open aai for long but
don't assume he'll automatically want to
join Microsoft he might want to rejoin
musk at xai found his own venture or
maybe go to Google I'm sure musk would
be delighted to have him and Ilia sukova
back musk is the guy that after all
persuaded sukova to join open AI in the
first place he said that Ilia has a good
moral compass and doesn't seek power he
wouldn't take such drastic action unless
he felt it was absolutely necessary that
does seem to me more of a pitch to get
satova and Co to join his team and my
own cheeky prediction is that anthropic
will make a move to merge with the
remnants of open AI until recently don't
forget most of the founding staff of
anthropic used to work at open Ai and
anthropic do seem to be much more safety
focused which would gel well with satova
I await with curiosity to see if
anthropic does pitch such a move it just
seems to make sense to me because that
would turn two smaller entities that
would struggle to match Google and
Microsoft into quite a formidable team
anthropic seems to certainly share
sata's views on super intelligence which
ilas sukova stated while sitting next to
samman fairly recently we talking about
as time goes by and the capability keeps
increasing you know and eventually it
goes all the way to here right right now
we are here today that's where we are
that's where we going to get to when we
get to this point then yeah it's very
powerful technology it can be used for
amazing applications you can say cure
all disease on the flip side you can say
create a disease much more worse than
anything that existed before that'd be
bad and in a somewhat prophetic
statement from two weeks ago SATA said
this you know I think we going going to
be a lot of disagreement going to be a
lots of political questions but I think
that as people see AI actually getting
better as people experience it the
desire for the
pro-social super intelligence the
humanity loving super intelligence you
know as much as this as as much as it
can be done will increase and on the
scientific problem you know I think
right now it's still being an area where
not that many people were working
on are AI are getting powerful enough
you can really start studying it
productively we'll have some very
exciting research to to share soon and
for anyone predicting that the open AI
remnants will be no match for Microsoft
it's not like that relationship won't
have its own challenges just this
morning SAA nadela the CEO of Microsoft
promised to allow them Independence they
would be building independent identities
within Microsoft that was in reply to
samman's tweet that the mission
continues to build AGI but is Microsoft
big enough for two such huge person
personalities ultman did once confess
that he relished the power of running
open Ai and foresaw making strange
decisions in the future I mean I have
like lots of selfish reasons for doing
this and as you said I get like all of
the Power of running open AI but I can't
think of like anything more fulfilling
to work on I don't think it's like
particularly altruistic it would be if I
like didn't already have a bunch of
money yeah the money is going to like
pile up faster than I can spend it
anyway I like being non-conflicted on
open AI cuz I think the chance that we
have to make a very strange decision
someday is non-trivial but now that he's
a worker within Microsoft will he be
able to make such strange decisions an
Oldman after all has talked in the past
about the importance of there being a
nonprofit board in charge like no one
person should be trusted here I don't
have super voting shares um like I don't
want them the board can fire me I think
that's important I think the board over
time needs to get like democratized to
all of humanity there's many ways that
could be implemented but the reason for
our structure and the reason it's so
weird and the one of the consequen of
that weirdness was me ending up with no
equity is we think this technology the
benefits the access to it the governance
of it belongs to humanity as a whole you
should like not if this really works
it's like quite a powerful technology
and you should not trust one company and
certainly not one person with it
whatever happens events over the last
few minutes hours and days will change
the course of AI we Face a far more
fractured landscape than we did a few
days ago go and as many people in my
comments have pointed out it just
reiterates how hard it is to align
humans let alone aligning a
superintelligence here's two current or
potentially former openai employees
disagreeing over why Ilia did it one as
we saw at the start saying that Ilia
does not care about safety or humanity
and another saying it wasn't a power
grab for selfish reasons it was more
about Ila's sense of a near sacred
mandate to avoid Doom at any cost let me
know what you think about what happened
and what it means my own take is that if
there's this much division when we're
not even that close to Super
intelligence we're not yet at the point
where trillions of dollars are on the
line and National Security is at stake
can you imagine the coordination that
will be required when we actually get
super intelligence anyway let me know
what you think it's time for me to have
breakfast have a wonderful day